the controversial social media
influencer Andrew Tate has been arrested
in Romania on suspicion of human
trafficking rape and forming an
organized crime group our correspondent
Ashna hernag is here with more
um for The uninitiated Who Is He And
what's he being accused of in more
detail well Andrew Tate is a former
kickboxer but as you mentioned there he
is a deeply controversial online
influencer who has been taken off
multiple platforms including Facebook
and Instagram for promoting hate speech
and misogynistic commentary in the past
some of the things that he said well
he's said suggested that victims of rape
bear some responsibility in their
assault women he's described them as
being property belonging to men and he's
described himself in his own words as
being the king of toxic masculinity last
night he was arrested in Bucharest where
he moved in 2017 with his brother he was
arrested alongside his brother Tristan
Tate on suspicion of human trafficking
rape and of forming an organized crime
group here's what he told reporters
outside
The Matrix has attacked me
so very short response from him LED away
there with his brother inside
um when they raided that property police
found guns they found knives and wads of
cash prosecutors say the four suspects
of two other Romanian Nationals also
arrested appear to have created an
organized crime group with the purpose
of recruiting they say housing and
exploiting women by forcing them to
create pornographic content meant to be
seen on Specialized websites the
brothers have declined to comment their
lawyer has acknowledged that yes they
have been detained it's reported though
that police needed proof that both these
brothers happened to be in the country
and they did that by allegedly
monitoring their social media sites and
since Andrew Tate has been engaging in a
Twitter rail some viewers may have seen
with climate activist Greta uh tunberg
in his latest
it did he's recently tweeted a video of
him alongside some pizza boxes belonging
to a Romanian company and that was
allegedly the way that police Went to
went on to find him
reacting in the last half an hour or so
tweeting this is what happens when you
don't recycle your pizza boxes so
reacting there to that means she doesn't
miss a trick does she no she doesn't but
he he will be uh detained and questioned
for the next uh 24 hours